mir geht es nämlich um klaus müller das
ist der neue chef der bundesnetzagentur
ein bemerkenswerter mann der tritt
tatsächlich so aus als würde karl
lauterbach ihnen coach mit seinen
ideen wie wir jetzt alle energie
einsparen können sollte man sicherlich
natürlich energie einsparen will das gas
möglicherweise aus russland am ende
abgeschaltet wird oder wie auch immer
das ist sicherlich hat seine durchaus
seine berechtigung aber dieser mann der
kommt hier mit vorschlägen der ist eine
nervensäge mittlerweile der sagt zum
beispiel so etwas wie singles in großen
wohnungen sollten diese großen wohnungen
nicht mehr so sehr heizen wie bisher der
sagt es reicht doch auch mal zehn grad
in der wohnung zum beispiel da sage ich
mir 17 grad warm ich es haben will oder
nicht das entscheide ich vielleicht als
bürger doch selbst und sein neuester
knaller ist er sagt wir müssen jetzt mal
überlegen ob es überhaupt noch
angemessen ist sieben mal die woche zu
duschen da sag ich mal dieser mann
überschreite seine kompetenz so hat das
bei karl lauterbach tauch angefangen ich
glaube wir werden von tausenden einiges
verloren aber
eindeutig lieber herr müller so hoch
hält es nicht ich dusche so lange und
wann ich will nicht zum frühdienst
fahren damit ich ja gebucht hingehen und
nicht ich weiß nicht wie oft er duscht
aber damit hat mal jemand neben ihm
gestanden
wir haben angefragt würden gerne mit ihm
sprechen immer sondershausen ideen und
er verweigert sich dem aber das wäre
genau meine frage wie oft müssen sie
denn ich kenne ich faktor ist jetzt
nicht mehr er muss sagen er war
umweltminister in schleswig-holstein ja
von den grünen und das ist ebenso dieses
hinein wirken in private lebensbereiche
was ich nicht in ordnung finde es gibt
eine sehr ernstzunehmende brücke
zwischen corona politik und der politik
die sie schildern die beginnt jetzt der
karl lauterbach hat von geschätzten jahr
oder anderthalb jahren mal gesagt dass
man die einschränkung der freiheit die
da eingeführt wurden auch später noch
brauchen werde zur durchsetzung der
klimapolitik so finanz der schlimmsten
satz den lauterbach überhaupt gesagt wo
es fast an schlimmsten das heißt wir das
war es eine mahnung an uns wir müssen
uns daran gewöhnen dass das dauerhaft
der fall ist erst acht ja auch diese
diese diese corona
pandemie werden wir noch 20 30 jahre
haben davor bewahren dass der himmel das
glauben wir nicht mehr da brauchte gar
nicht mehr mitzukommen aber wenn es
andere gibt die das aufnehmen in der
klimapolitik und die sagen jetzt müssen
wir auch freiheitsbeschränkungen bewegt
beschränkung unsere beweglichkeit und so
weiter dort einführen dann haben wir ein
echtes problem
und es sind viele die das aufnehmen in
gewerkschaften in den kirchen wann beim
weltwirtschaftsforum in davos
erstaunlicherweise zum teil auch in den
unternehmen und da gruselt es mir dann
also wirklich auch sehr und ich finde es
genial waren sind wie du es bleibt immer
wieder nennen ja und es gibt ja eine
interessante parallele die ich noch sehr
pikant findet sozusagen es hat ja vor
einigen jahren mal theo sarrazin gesagt
man müsste ja für mich immer die wohnung
ganz so hoch halten und kann er
vielleicht auch mal ein wollpullover
überziehen das ging dann in richtung hat
hier empfänger es wurde sehr negativ
aufgenommen also im grunde seine ächtung
begann auch also unter anderem mit der
kritik an will man an diesen an diesem
satz wenn ein grüner das sagt ist es
offensichtlich in ordnung mit 17 gerade
in der wohnung bin ich einverstanden
wenn es draußen 35h
hdr handeln gesehen sind das dann sind
wir deutschen vielleicht auch einfach
freiheits faul dass wir überhaupt so
etwas akzeptieren
ja also freiheit hat nicht so eine
richtig große tradition ja dann muss man
sagen im verhältnis zu anderen ländern
und was ist ja im grunde schlimm da auch
an dem beispiel ist wie jetzt gerade die
der schlimme krieg in der ukraine
instrumentalisiert wird um jetzt alle
diese möglichen einschränkungen zu
begründen also jetzt kommen die uns
sagen
tempobeschränkung auf der autobahn und
so weiter also ganz alte forderungen die
jetzt aber alle recycelt werden aber
alle mit der neuen begründung also wir
müssen jetzt der ukraine helfen und
deswegen müssen wir jetzt weniger
duschen jahren deswegen müssen wir das
ist im grunde genommen also chemisch so
ein ganz schlimmes ein ernstes thema so
zu instrumente da es gibt ja eine breite
bewegung den freiheitsbegriff überhaupt
zu zerlegen denn beobachte schon eine
ganze zeit und zwar gedruckten in
artikeln von von politikwissenschaftlern
von philosophen von kulturschaffenden
ich hab da neulich im deutschlandfunk an
einem samstagvormittag samstag war das
glaube ich oder sonntag bin ich mir ganz
sicher
einen langen vortrag eines
wissenschaftlers gehört der sich darauf
spezialisiert hat in dieser sendung
deutschlandfunk den freiheitsbegriff zu
zerlegen dass der
inflationär gebraucht werden dass man
ihn gar nicht mehr so brauche das er
überholt sei das ist um verantwortung
gehe nicht mehr um freiheit und
ähnliches und diesen tenor ich habe das
auch gedruckt gesehen in artikeln da
muss man sehr darauf achten und man muss
dann finde ich wenn anders begegnet
sofort dagegen auf aber das wird von
vielen kollegen durchaus vertreten ja
und also meine philosophie so sagt meine
beschäftigung mit philosophie ist zu
lange her ich könnte nicht sagen ob das
eigentlich hegel oder marxist aber es
wird jetzt immer definiert also freiheit
als einsicht in die notwendigkeit oder
auslassungen des umstandes dass
irgendjemand bestimmen muss rasten die
notwendigkeit ist wo er muss man erstmal
fall gewesen sein denn auch man
beschränkt ja und wer definiert ihn und
wenn ich absolut also kann ich ihnen
zustimmen ich habe da selbst ein ganz
eigenartiges erlebnis gehabt ich
schreibe ja öfters für die neue zürcher
zeitung und da habe ich einen
antikapitalistischen philosophen
kritisiert und er hat also eine replik
gegen mich geschrieben und dann schreibt
der titel mann ist ein prediger der
freiheit das war beides nicht als
kompliment gemeint vergiftet das war
praktisch das war die höchste form der
geringschätzung und da hab ich gesagt
also das ziel kann also prediger der
freiheit finde ich gar nicht verkehrt
ein einstieg sein letztes freiheits nazi
bezeichnet
dementsprechend die freiheit hat zum
wenig lobby nimmst du das auch im moment
ja das nehme ich tatsächlich so warm wie
gesagt dass hineinwirken im privaten
lebensbereich der politik und das auch
das moralische aufladen wie sich eben
auch schon sagten dass man sagt also
tempolimit der stelle auf wert als 130
oder wir gegen die wir gegen ein
tempolimit ist der riskiert er der führt
quasi den krieg in der ukraine mit oder
so da das ist einfach nicht in ordnung
genauso bei der korona politik wer dazu
kritische anmerkungen hat der will dass
möglichen sterben das ist natürlich
völliger unsinn oder bei der
flüchtlingspolitik damit das natürlich
auch ganz massiv gesehen auch tausende
freundschaften zerbrochen haben wir ja
auch schon darüber gesprochen das ist
natürlich dramatisch ich finde es
schlimm wir sind offensichtlich als land
oder als gesellschaft in deutschland
nicht in der lage bestimmte themen in
einer gesellschaftlichen debatte zu
verhandeln ohne andere auszugrenzen und
zu schlecht menschen zu erklären das
nehme ich in groß wird zb anderes waren
gut die haben sich über den black series
oft sage ich auch dazu aber wir haben
offensichtlich nicht diese kultur wie
das in den angelsächsischen ländern ist
dass man in einer debatte argumente
austauschen ohne den anderen abzuwerten
und zum schlechten menschen zu erklären
ja also wir haben sehr komische stimmung
hier immer jan ein schwarzweiß freund
feind leben oder tod durch und und
zwischentöne sind nicht so dass ich sage
ich aber auch mal was ich jetzt an der
kroate debatte trotzdem wissen skifahren
also dass man sie regel sehr über die
masken mehr auf ich sehe ja aber ich hab
mal wenn sich die leute genauso
aufregend würden auch über andere
freiheitseinschränkung ja zum beispiel
einschränkung der wirtschaftlichen
freiheit es gibt in deutschland 25.000
bauvorschriften das ist auch für mich
ein lehrer
und auch die ganze sagen wir
einschränkungen in der der geistige
freiheit das ist für mich so ein
hauptthema finde ich auch ein bisschen
schade bei meiner eigenen partei als
spinne seit 26 jahren der fdp und ich
habe immer gesagt die beiden hauptthemen
müssten doch sein dass wir für die
wirtschaftliche freiheit eintreten aber
auch für die geistige freiheit einträten
also gegen diese reifen korrekt
sonderthema bauvorschriften nochmal
wiederkommen
wird durch spannende diskussion er ist
nämlich wert irrsinnig was sich da
abspielt aber das mit den
bauvorschriften spannendes thema haben
wir jetzt vielleicht einfach durch
corona erst mal bemerkt wie sehr unsere
freiheit beschnitten wird und reagieren
jetzt vielleicht auch das erste mal
drauf naja ich finde es ja gut wenn es
auch auf andere bereiche übertragen wird
aber ich habe so das gefühl das ist
eigentlich nicht so geschieht also die
leute regen sich sehr über diese ganzen
chor ohne beschränkungen auf aber ich
habe jetzt nicht erfahren dass die
menschen nicht im gleichen maße aufregen
über die ständige beschränkung von
wirtschaftlicher freiheit die ich viel
gefährlicher finde noch also da müssten
wir mehr darüber sprechen naja und auch
ein diskurs klima eben dass das also
sehr unversöhnlich ist und also die
andere meinung ist eben nicht anders
oder von mir aus schlecht argumentiert
und so sind sie ist böse ist unmoralisch
und das ist ich habe aber auch kein
richtiges mittel wie man davon wieder
runterkommen ich habe den eindruck das
ist in den vergangenen jahren wirklich
noch mal dramatisch schlimmer geworden
in den letzten weiß ich die fünf sechs
jahren also es war als tendenz immer
schon vorhanden und es gab natürlich
seit 20 30 jahren debatten über
politische correctness die aus den
amerikanischen universitäten in
generationen auch zu sein ja her
schwappte aber ich finde es hat noch mal
einen schub der unversöhnlich aber es
gibt auch mehr widerspruch guck mal ich
meinen viele herr jörges zum beispiel ja
so früher war ich da auch manchmal
andere meinung als er heute auch noch
manchmal aber aber dann sind die
schwierigkeiten irgendjemandem zwar
ist doch nur natürlich ja aber weil ich
das sagt doch mal das eben auch leute
die die wir heute brauchen und die die
auch laut ihre stimme erheben und von
denen gibt es eigentlich ich würde sagen
er mehr als vor 20 jahren also es werden
ein gefühlt ja mein möglich ist anders
ich glaube dass die medien sehr eintönig
geworden sind und das ist nur noch
wenige leitartikler beispielsweise in
großen zeitungen gibt die so schreiben
dass man sie lesen will mir geht es so
wie es euch geht es ist eine
stromlinienförmigkeit eingerissen dass
man sehr schaut was machen die anderen
mit ihren die anderen passe ich daran
das spektrum und so dass das nehme ich
tatsächlich auf halte ich auch für sehr
problematisch ich finde man sollte immer
die die ergebnisse seiner eigenen
recherche und insofern auch eine
entsprechende kommentierung bringen und
nicht irgendwie sich auf ein meinungs-
korridor verengen lassen das ist
eigentlich der tod des journalismus wenn
man so agiert also ich finde es
eigentlich bei den printmedien gutmann
hat die welt man hat die neue züricher
zeitung als die bild zeitung da gibt es
noch eine gewisse ausgewogenheit ja aber
im fernsehen ja und ich rede nicht nur
von öffentlichen rechtes feinsinnig rede
auch vom privaten fans also ist ja hier
mal eine ausnahme nennen sie mir noch
mal eine nicht klinke talkshow in
deutschland eine dezidiert sagen wir mal
konservative oder von mir aus auch
libertäre oder was weiß ich was ich
würde sowas gerne moderieren das letzte
wort aber
einfach in einigen ländern sie können
sie noch jörges der decke hat löwenthal
war doch eigentlich der letzte
konservative oder knofi soll sei aber
noch nicht mit lange her und seitdem
also egal was man da sieht ob das die
länder oder meischberger sich dass die
alle dezitiert links sind aber es gibt
auch keinen einzigen jetzt mal mehr sagt
das ist jetzt dass wir doch auch dazu
gehören zum pluralismus dass man das so
dass jetzt eine wird dabei wie der titel
man dann machst du einen ganz anderen
hört sie sind halt alle so mainstreamig
dass er dann keine meinungen mehr
feststellt oder einlädt dorthin die
irgendwie mal aus dem rahmen fallen was
die leitartikler angeht ich kann mich
noch ein robert leicht bei der
süddeutschen zeitung genau da ist dann
später zur zeit gegangen bei der
süddeutschen zeitung war ein
leitartikler der richtig eigen eine
eigen stellung hatte weil er dinge so
kommentiert hat wie sie andere nicht
kommentiert haben da hat man schon
alleine angefangen zu lesen weil sein
name schon über stand und das sehe ich
heute bei der süddeutschen zeitung nicht
mehr aber das gilt ja für die themen
insgesamt also früher wenn sie als als
volontärin kam mit dem thema und gesagt
haben ein toller artikel in der
süddeutschen kann ich darüber schreiben
hat der chef gesagt nee wieso ist eine
geschichte der süddeutschen also wenn du
nichts ganz neues hast vergiss es heute
fragt jeder stefan haben geht es nicht
auch also es ist eine selbst
gleichschaltung raum stehen
entsprechenden aufruf dass ich das
verbessert und der aufruf von herr
doktor doktor einer zehn mann dass er
gerne öffentlich rechtlichen
freundlicher muss man tauschen doch wenn
einem der räder zuschauer wir haben hier
einen bewerber und ich verspreche ihnen
bei uns darf man ja alles sagen was man
möchte müssen wir das reich der freiheit
und ich glaube die these die jetzt
olivia wyss mit hat die würden sie auch
nicht im öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk
hören